So, bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Schon guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Amit Topbu, ich bin hier als Assistant, als Stetig
und würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahmespech führen.
Bitte fragen Sie nachher, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay? Ja, klar.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Claudia Thomas.
Claudia Thomas.
Claudia mit C oder?
Mit C vorne, genau.
D-L-A-U-D-I-R.
Genau.
Ja.
Und Thomas...
Wir müssen ein weiblicher Vorname, ne?
Okay.
Und T-H-O...
Thomas mit T-H am Anfang.
T-H-T-H-O-M-A-S, okay.
Genau.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 27 Jahre alt.
Sieben und 20.
19 genau geworden.
Am 17, 2. 95.
Siebten.
Zwuten, 95.
95.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 79 kg.
79.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 m.
Okay.
Frau Thomas, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich bin gerade mit dem Fahrrad-Unterwies gewesen.
Und es war schon dunkel, ne?
Und dann habe ich eine Baustelle übersehen
und bin irgendwie mit dem Fahrrad in diese Absperrung reingefahren.
Und ja, jetzt habe ich solche Schmerzen.
Ich bin auf die linke Seite gefallen.
Und es tut mir der Kopf weh
und der Bauch tut mir weh.
Und mein Freund hat mich begleitet.
Der war mit unterwegs und der sagt,
ich wäre einen kleinen Moment auch weg gewesen.
Ich wäre also nicht bei Bewusstsein gewesen.
Und...
Aber ihr habt ihr Bewusstsein verloren, oder?
Ja, ja, ich weiß es nicht mehr,
was da passiert ist.
Aber das kriegt man ja selber nicht mit.
Aber er hat gesagt, ich wäre kurz weg gewesen.
Und ja, jetzt tut mir halt die ganze linke Körperseite weh.
Und ja, mir ist auch schlecht.
Und ich musste mich einmal übergeben.
Und mir ist schwindelig.
Und ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, die ganze linke Seite
tut mir weh.
Okay.
Wir haben sie hier gekommen.
Mein Freund hat mich mit dem Auto gebracht.
Mit Auto.
Okay.
Haben Sie einen Helm auf dem Kopf?
Ich halte den Helm auf, ja.
Okay, Sie haben einen.
Und ja, Sie haben diese weg, diese...
nicht gesehen, aber...
Wann war das?
Haben Sie erinnern, dass diese...
Wann?
Das ist jetzt ungefähr 2 Stunden her, oder 1,5 Stunden her.
2 Stunden.
Okay.
Haben Sie das?
Ihr hört, dass ihr von ihr Freundin
wie lange dauert diese Bewusstsein verloscht?
Das war nur ganz kurz.
Vielleicht an 2 Minuten, oder so.
Kurze Zeit.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Kopfschmerzen,
nicht?
Haben Sie Ihre Kopf einstoßen, oder?
Das weiß ich gar nicht so genau, was da passiert ist.
Also der Kopf tut weh, und der linke Oberarm
gibt es...
Ich habe noch nicht so genau geguckt.
Wahrscheinlich ist das alles blau,
und unterlaufen, aber ich habe noch nicht so genau geguckt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Nackenschmerzen?
Nee.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen auch?
Ja.
Gibt es Farbeanderungen?
Auf diesem Bauch haben Sie sich bemerkt?
Oder wo?
Ich glaube eher so an der Seite,
dass da blaue Flecken sind,
oder dass das jetzt im Augenblick ist,
das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie rot,
oder wird es blau, keine Ahnung.
Linke Seite, ja?
Okay.
Sie haben...
Okay, gesehen ist blau.
Ja, ich denke, ich habe nur das Gefühl,
dass das anschwillt, ne?
Okay. Haben Sie Schmerzen dort?
Ja, eigentlich tut mir alles weh, jetzt da auf der linken Seite.
Aber besonders der Oberarm,
und der Bauch, und der Kopf.
Diese Schmerzen im Bauch,
das ist ein sehr leckeres Bauch.
Können Sie das oder?
Kann ich nicht so richtig sagen,
ich glaube die Strahlen nicht aus.
Okay.
Wie stark ist die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerz kann man zum Beispiel einst,
sehr leicht, sehr stark.
Also, an der Körperseite vielleicht,
so bei 5, 6,
aber der Arm, der tut schon richtig doll weh.
Da würde ich sagen, das ist schon 8, ne?
8.
Okay.
Haben Sie Bewegung, kann ich schwenken?
Im Gesamtarm?
Ja, ich kann den jetzt im Augenblick,
kann ich den nicht bewegen, ja.
Oberarm, Unterarm oder?
Oberarm.
Und gibt es hier auch Schwellungen, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Können Sie Ihre Schulter bewegen?
Die Schulter?
Ja.
Nur der Arm selber nicht.
Haben Sie Lähmungen?
Können Sie gut Ihre Finger bewegen?
Die Finger kann ich bewegen, ja.
Wie bitte?
Ich kann die Finger bewegen, ja.
Nicht?
Sie sind nicht gelähmt, die Finger kann ich bewegen.
Ah, okay. Fingergut.
Okay.
Okay, dann.
Sie haben gesagt, Kopfschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen
und Armschmerzen auch.
Haben Sie Schmerzen auf die Beine?
Die linken Beine?
Ja, so ein bisschen an der Hüfte,
wo man so draufhält, ne?
Da ist es irgendwie auch ein bisschen schmerzhaft,
aber nicht so schlimm wie im oberen Bereich.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, mir ist schlecht, ne?
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben einmal übergeben
und fühlen sich schwindelig.
Okay.
Nachdem
diesem Unfall
haben Sie
ein Nassen bemerkt oder?
Nee.
Okay, dann.
Ja, ich möchte
allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Allgemeine Zustand, Ihre.
Wie ist Ihre Schlaf?
Können Sie kurz schlafen?
Normalerweise eigentlich schon.
Okay.
Jetzt haben Sie Übelkeit.
Jetzt ist mir schlecht, ja.
Okay.
Und schwindelig auch.
Schweißausbrücke?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Er ist mir kalt.
Okay.
Normalerweise?
Normalerweise ist es so gut.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Zugang?
Normalerweise ja, bin ich ein bisschen verstopft, ja.
Wasserlassen?
Was ist?
Ja, also ich hatte mal eine Nierenbeckenentzündung.
Da war das mit dem Wasserlassen nicht so angenehm,
aber das war, ist schon fünf Jahre her.
Da habe ich da keine Probleme.
Fünf Jahre? Was los?
Ah.
Nierenbeckenentzündung.
Okay.
Aber jetzt, Sie fühlen sich gut, ja?
Ja, von der hin nicht, ja.
Okay. Und jetzt haben Sie kein Problem mit Wasserlassen.
Immer auch nicht, das hat nicht mehr.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, bei mir ist eine
Hashimoto-Schildrisenerkrankung bekannt.
Das habe ich jetzt schon seit zehn Jahren.
Da muss ich halt Tiroxin einnehmen, ne?
Wie viel Mikrogramm nehmen Sie?
75 einmal morgens.
77?
75.
Okay, morgens.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere weitere Erkrankungen?
Ne, sonst ist eigentlich alles klar.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ne, noch nie.
Okay. Außer dieser Unfall haben Sie
andere Unfall gemacht?
Ne, bisher zum Glück noch nicht.
Nehmen Sie weitere Medikamente,
außer Erkroxin?
Ja, Iguprofen, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe oder so.
Und ja, ich habe immer
ein leicht waden Kremse. Und deswegen
regelmäßig Magnesium ein.
Sie haben was? Kremse?
Wadenkremse.
Okay, Sie nehmen Magnesium.
Nehmen Sie?
Okay, wann nehmen Sie das?
Mittags.
Okay.
Andere Medikamente?
Sonst nichts mehr.
Ne, das mache ich so mit Diät, also beziehungsweise mit
Nahrungsmitteln, die so ein bisschen abführen.
Okay. Haben Sie Allergien gegen Flaster, Kontrast,
eigentlich nur...
Ich habe nur eine sehr heftige
Bienenallergie auf Bienenstiche.
Und deswegen habe ich
auch immer so ein Adrenalin-Pen bei mir.
Oh, okay.
Und tatsächlich kann ich auch
kein braunes Pflaster vertragen.
Braunes Pflaster vertragen, problematisch.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir
wie Ihre Familie.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Sie haben gesagt, sie sind mit
Vater gekommen.
Nein, mit meinem Freund bin ich gekommen.
Ah.
Mit Auto? Sie haben gesagt?
Ja, mein Freund hat mich mit dem Auto gebracht.
Ah.
Okay.
Okay. Ist Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, mein Vater, da ist es bis jetzt
waren alle gesund. Mein Vater hat die jetzt
vor zwei Wochen tatsächlich eine Bypass-Operation
am Herzen.
Bypass. Okay. Ihre Mutter?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich eine Zwillingsschwester.
Und der geht es tatsächlich nicht gut.
Die leidet unter einer Manifestendepression.
Depression.
Zwillen, ja.
Das ist meine Zwillingsschwester, ja.
Zwillingsschwester. Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein. Okay.
Ähm.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Thomas?
Nein, brauchen tu ich nicht.
Okay, drin gibt es Alkohol?
Ja, sehr selten mal.
Weil bei einem Käst oder bei einer Party, aber
normalerweise nicht.
Heute haben Sie Alkohol genommen oder?
Nee, da habe ich gar nichts getrunken.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht überall, aber
haben Sie Sorgen probiert?
Ja, also manchmal
habe ich schon Mario Hanna probiert.
Wie oft?
Ha, weil Gelegenheit, wenn man irgendwie
bei einer guten Party ist oder so,
das, was ich, 15, 20 mal.
Fisch. 15 bis 20 mal in meinem Leben.
Noch nicht oft.
Nicht regelmäßig. Okay.
Ähm.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Okay, leben Sie mit?
Ihre Familie oder?
Ich wohne in der Wohngemeinschaft.
Okay, Sie leben in einer Wohngemeinschaft.
Ich bin Studentin.
Studentin. Okay.
Okay, Frau Thomas.
Dieser Fahrradunfall, Sie haben gesagt,
ja, Sie haben
genutzt, das ist gut.
Okay, dann.
Ja, ähm.
Wo
waren Sie gehen oder
warum waren Sie auf dem Weg?
Ich war auf dem Heimweg von einem Fest.
Heimweg.
Okay.
Und Sie haben diese Baustelle
nicht gesehen und dann?
Dann bin ich irgendwie gegen die Absperrung gefahren.
Absperrung.
Okay.
Vor diesem
Unfall
haben Sie andere
Dinge bemerkt oder zum Beispiel Ihre Begrüßung
vor diesem Unfall
verloren oder
vor der Orgeln.
Also, dass ich deswegen reingefahren bin, weil ich, weil mir vorher schlecht war.
Und ich habe nur nicht gut geguckt, im Dunkeln
und bin da irgendwie reingerauscht in diese Absperrung.
Okay.
Alles klar. Okay, dann.
Jetzt nehmen wir Sie Stationärn nehmen.
Ja.
Und ich
glaube, ich bin für Sie nicht bettkrieg, weil es geht mir wirklich nicht gut.
Ich möchte Sie untersuchen.
Und außerdem
Röntgen, Aufnahme nehmen.
Und
Ultraschall Abdomen
luchtet. Was kann man da so sehen?
Und Blut nehmen.
Blut abnehmen.
Okay.
Ja, wie das meint Sie denn? Wie lange muss ich denn da bleiben?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, als erstes muss ich ihr untersuchen
und ihr
diese,
Was wie sagen das?
Als erstes
muss ich diese
Blutabnahme
untersuchen.
Und dann können wir über das specken.
Dann sehen wir, wie es weitergeht. Okay.
Gut.
Kann es sein, dass ich operiert werden muss?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Schauen wir dann.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Heute, ich dachte, wie dieser Fall,
ich habe das früher nicht
gemacht.
Wieso? Ja,
in Simulation oder andere.
Ich dachte das heute.
Sie haben gedacht,
heute kommt was, was ich noch nie gemacht habe.
Ja, ja. Ah, ja, okay.
Das ist, das ist übrigens
ein Münchner Fall.
Den habe ich mir nicht aus den Fingern gesogen, sondern das ist
ein Münchner Fall. Die Bayern
müssen auch Traumapazienten machen.
Ja? Okay.
Ich bin auch in Niedersachsen.
Meine typische Frau.
Bitte was? Auch
in Niedersachsen.
Muss man auch Traumapazienten können.
Kann man mal sehen. Es ist tatsächlich von
Bundesland zu Bundesland völlig unterschiedlich.
Das ist total verrückt.
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Sind Sie vorstandig?
Auch gegen Corona?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Und wann er folgte
letzte Ihre Tetanus-Impfung?
Tetanus-Impfung? Ach du Schande.
Ja, gute Frage. Ich glaube, das ist schon
sehr lange her. Als Kind, als ich mal
vom Baum gefallen bin oder so. Aber
das ist schon wirklich sehr lange her. Ich glaube, die
müsste dringend aufgefrischt werden.
Danke. Das war eine wichtige Frage.
Ich kann meine Finger nicht
zu bewegen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich kann sie bewegen.
Das ist ein falscher Stand.
Erst einmal habe ich das gehört
und dann kontrolliert.
Ja, okay.
Beide Male, ich kann die Finger bewegen.
Können Sie ihr Beine
rechten?
Ihr Oberarm, Unterarm.
Und auch ihr Nacken.
Können Sie ganz gut bewegen?
Den Nacken hat er schon gefragt.
Das Bein bewegt ein bisschen Wehbein.
Den Arm kann ich gar nicht bewegen.
Können Sie auf ihren Bein
treten?
Ja, das kann ich.
Vor dem Unfall,
habe ich eine Alkoholkonsum?
Vor dem Unfall.
Ja.
Alkohol, nee, ich habe nichts getrunken
heute Abend.
Auch nicht, auch nicht
Marihuana geraucht.
Heute mal nicht.
Ich trinke gerade nur Blümchen.
Das ist auch eine interessante Frage.
Das ist eine richtige, zum Beispiel,
Kopfschmerzen mit einer Welkeit zu schwindelig?
Das habe ich beschrieben.
Ich habe gesagt, mir ist schlecht, ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Ich musste mich übergeben. Mir ist schwindelig.
Das ganze Programm.
Es gibt ja auch einen Unterschied.
Rechts und links gibt es nicht.
Das ist zumindest nicht beschrieben.
Gibt es irgendwelche
Gliedermassen?
Er hat nur nach
einer Motorik gefragt, aber ich habe auch
keine Erfindungsstörung.
Die Hand kribbelt nicht.
Ich habe gesehen, da war
etwas, aber ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Oh Gott, Alzheimer.
Irgendwas hat sie gerade gefragt.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie so flimmert mein Bild.
Flimmert das bei ihnen auf?
Mein Bild wackelt ganz schrecklich.
Da wird mir ja betrunken.
Flimmert das bei ihnen auf?
Bei mir wackelt mein eigenes Bild.
Das sieht gut aus.
Ich werde es fast sehkrank, wenn ich da reingucke.
Nicht das hier an meinem Bildschirm.
Können wir schon?
Ich habe nicht mehr gesehen.
Ein bisschen.
Okay, dann machen wir anderen noch ein bisschen Smalltalk.
Irgendjemand hätte gerade noch
schriftlich eine Frage reingegeben,
die ich aber irgendwie nicht
rechtzeitig gesehen habe.
Ich habe gefragt, warum die offene Wunde bemerkt.
Das war es.
Ich habeüsse noch nicht nachgeguckt.
Sie hat also noch nicht pastel
und sich nicht ausgezogen.
Sie hat auch noch nicht fre Wayne
lookeder.
Die Überraschung kommt gleich
bei der Untersuchung.
Guten Abend.
Schön guten Abend.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Ich habe die Zeit für mich.
Ja, sicher.
Okay.
Der Patient ist Frau Thomas, Frau Claudio Thomas.
27 Jahre alt, 79 kg, 174 cm groß.
Sie kamen uns nach einem Fahrradunfall.
Sie waren auf dem Heimweg.
Sie hatten eine Absperrung,
nicht gesehen und gefahren
und auf linker Seite gefallen.
Es war zwei Stunden her.
Sie haben außerdem ein Helm getragen.
Sie haben ein Helm getragen.
sagen. Okay. Und jetzt habe sie Kopfschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen und außerdem linke Oberarmschmerzen.
Außerdem habe diese Patient gesagt, einmal Erwente sie einmal im Mesis und nausia.
Ja und sie haben keine offene Wunde bemerkt. Sie können ihre Linke nicht gut bewegen.
Und mit Bauch habe sie gesagt, Bauch ist blau jetzt. Sie haben blau Farbe in linke Seite. Es gibt auch Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala 5 bis 6 aufsehen.
Und es gibt keine Ausstrahlung und diese Armschmerzen war sehr schlecht. Es war 8 von 10.
Haben Sie ihr Schmerzmittel gegeben? Noch nicht.
Okay. Und jetzt, außer dem dieser Patient die Oberarm nicht gut bewegen, aber sie können Schulter gut bewegen und Finger auch.
Und es gibt keine Lehmung Erscheinungen auch. Ja, vegetativ an einem Nestig erwähnte sie Obstipation.
Und vor Erkrankungen haben sie vor 5 Jahren Nefritis und Hashimoto seit 10 Jahren und wogegen Nehmeseltroxin 75 Mikrogramm einmal morgens.
Außer dem Nehmesey Bay Bedarf für Kopfschirmersen Ibuprofen und Nehmesey Magnesium Wegen Wadenkranfe.
Wadenkranfe.
Sie haben Allergien gegen Bienenstiche. Sie haben eine Allergie. Außer dem sie nicht gut vertragen Brown-Flaster.
Sie verträgt nicht gut Brown-Flaster.
Und Familien an einem Nestig erwähnte sie Bay-Bas-OP, Bay-Muffater und Depression bei Geschwister und Zivilingsgeschwister.
Und die Noxin Analyse ergab Maruyana Konsum.
Regelmäßig?
Nicht regelmäßig. Bei meinem Partys sie hat gesagt.
Und kein Alkohol?
Ja, kein Alkohol. Sehr selten sie hat gesagt.
Schließlich sie sei ledig und lebe in einer Wege und sei Studentin.
Okay.
Gut, was haben Sie jetzt als erstes mit ihr gemacht?
Als erstes muss ich eine, was Zugang legen.
Was machen wir als erstes?
Wir überwachen erst mal die Vitalparameter.
Wir haben das zunehmend aufgenommen?
Ja, natürlich.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Als erstes dachte ich für Kranium, Kontosio-Serebri, für Arme, Humerusfraktur und für Bauch, Milztruktur.
Milztruktur? Okay, ja.
Okay, zur weiteren Abklärung.
Müssen wir nach der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Worauf gucken Sie besonders bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Als erstes möchte ich Bauch kontrollieren.
Diese blaue Verfolgung zu sehen.
Das ist wichtig.
Außer dem akut, was Wert-Hart-Bauch kontrollieren.
Ach, ob der Bauch hart wird?
Ja, okay.
Das ist wichtig.
Was machen Sie da kurzfristig, operativ?
Operativ, ja, ultrischal.
Einmal mit Zahlkopf drauf.
Kontrollieren, ja, das ist wichtig.
Das ist das.
Für Humerusfraktur müssen wir ein Röntgen Humerus unter Oberangesweihebenen genommen.
Und für Kontosiosereppe müssen wir Kranjalsc.
Das ist richtig.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat keine Besprühe mit Nacken und Torax.
Aber ich möchte ein Torax Röntgen.
Auf alle Fälle.
Ich habe mich das rippe angeknackst.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung,
was gucken Sie hinsichtlich der Neurologie?
Als erstes ist Lähmung wichtig.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, sie können gut bewelgen.
Sie können das sehen.
Und außerdem, Beinkontroll auch.
Das ist wichtig.
Und außerdem,
gucken Sie mal.
Wo sind die Reflexe?
Ja, natürlich.
Was ist wichtig?
Okay.
Ja, okay, gut.
Bevor Sie geräumt haben,
was wären sichere Frakturzeichen?
Sicherer Frakturzeichen.
Ja, es gibt Patientin gesagt, Schwellung dort.
Außer dem.
Ich möchte das Bewergung kontrollieren.
Kontrollieren?
Kontrollieren.
Ja.
Was können wir noch sehen?
Hören.
Was sind sichere Frakturzeichen?
Was kribben?
Krippitation.
Es tut mir weh, wenn ich das allein denke.
Aber es ist, ja, das Knirschen bei Bewegung klappt.
Und eben auch die sichtbare Fehlstellung.
Als Zeichen der Fraktur.
Manchmal kann man es ja wirklich schon direkt erkennen.
Gut.
Was machen Sie labormäßig?
Labormäßig.
Okay.
Und auch.
Und Blutbild.
In der Zeit.
Kontrollieren.
Und.
Und nach gucken Sie da besonders.
Lebenswerte.
Leberwerte.
Ich meine noch etwas.
Was ist das?
Ich meine noch etwas anderes.
Wenn wir an die Milz noch mal denken.
Milz.
Kontrollieren.
Ja, ich denke vor allem, wenn die jetzt tatsächlich eine innere Blutung hat,
dann müsste die ein HB-Apfalte kriegen.
Ja, natürlich.
Das meinte ich eigentlich.
Ich würde mich auch bestimmen, falls wir operieren müssen.
PTT, APTT, innere, innere.
Kontrollieren.
Und die Blutgruppe wäre nicht schlecht.
Ja, Blutgruppe.
Blutgruppe, Blutgruppe, dass wir, dass wir in Zweifelzfall was zum
Transfondieren haben.
Gut.
Genau.
Da müsste man tatsächlich auch dann nochmal fragen,
ob wir das nicht machen.
Wenn wir das nicht machen,
dann müssen wir das nicht denken.
Wann hat die zuletzt gegessen?
Wäre eine nicht ganz unwichtige Frage.
Die Anästhesisten werden es Ihnen danken.
Ja.
Gut.
Wenn Sie jetzt schon ausgehen,
dass die tatsächlich, also eine Komotio hat.
Und vielleicht den Arm gebrochen.
Was machen wir denn therapeutisch?
Therapeutisch.
Ja, als ist es, wir müssen diese
Röntgen sägen.
Und es gibt noch zum Beispiel, es gibt ein Bruch.
Und dann, es gibt Möglichkeiten.
Als ist es, es kann operieren,
operiert wurden.
Und soweit es ein Gips.
Also konservativ.
Okay.
Genau, den genügend Zugang haben Sie schon gemacht.
Genau.
Wie sieht das denn
mit der Trombose-Profilaxe aus?
Niedrig.
Ja, Heparin.
Aber Niedrigmolyke...
Niedermolekulares Heparin.
Ja, aber schon sofort.
Geben wir schon gleich, Heparin?
Ah, ASS, wir können das.
Wir können...
Ne, was müssen wir erst abwarten?
Was müssen wir erst abwarten?
Bevor wir die Gerinnung runterhauen.
Wir müssen gucken, ob die Milz in Ordnung ist.
Erst wenn die Milz-Rruktur ausgeschlossen ist.
Erst wenn die Milz-Rruktur ausgeschlossen ist,
kann man mit die Gerinnung runterfahren.
Vorher riskiert man ja, dass die blutet.
Wie verrückt.
Okay.
Im-dim-dim-dim-dim-dim.
Ja, hier hatten die Prüfer noch eine Frage.
Warum Schädel-CT?
Die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat einmal MS,
und dann noch eine.
Wir müssen die Gerinn kontrollieren.
Ja, und was wollen wir ausgießen?
Ja, die Gerinnblutung.
Ja, genau.
Dass die eine Blutung hat im subar-neu-idal Raum.
Dass die da nicht irgendwo einblutet.
Der langt manchmal wirklich ein kleines Trauma.
Das waren die Prüferfragen noch.
Ja.
Von meiner Seite aus ist das jetzt alles geklärt.
Dann würde ich jetzt sagen,
kümmern Sie sich um Ihre Patientin,
halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, wie es ihr geht.
Ja?
Gut.
Ja, hat von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch jemand
einen Hinweis zu dieser Patientin?
Offensichtlich sind alle zufrieden und begeistert.
Ich weiß, dass alle nicht so gerne Trauma-Patienten haben.
Aber es gibt nur mal Trauma-Patienten.
Das ist so.
Ich konnte etwas sagen.
Meistern, Fahrradunfallen,
gibt eine Probleme mit dem Pankrers.
Wegen Fahrradlenker.
Fahrradlenker.
Da kommt gerade die Bauch-Oberbauch-Meisters.
Und verletzt die die Pankrers.
So eine Fälle habe ich erlebt.
Selbst erlebt?
Ja.
Deswegen weiß ich, manchmal so etwas passiert.
Natürlich, wir sind schon den Milz verletzten.
Oft die Traumatizen.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ein bisschen naheliegend.
Mit dem Milz, das hätte ich naheliegend gefunden.
Das kenne ich diesen Mechanismus.
Mit dem Fahrradlenker und dem Oberbauch.
Das ist ein Klassiker.
Man merkt das nicht sofort.
Weil es die innere und äußere Milz-Sruktur gibt.
Dass die Kapsel erst zu einer späteren Zeitung reist.
Solange sind die Leute unauffällig.
Aber ein Pankrers ist tatsächlich eine Idee,
dass man auch mal gucken muss.
Das liegt ja unmittelbar in der Nachbarschaft.
Ja, genau.
Was macht man, wenn der Pankrers etwas abgekriegt hat?
Beobachten wir,
kommt eine Pankrers, nicht große Nutzer nicht.
Ein paar Tage, ein Wochen umgeführt.
Das ist eine sehr große Nachbarschaft.
Dann haben wir eine Hospital oder eine Bleibung bekommen.
Die passieren im Krankenhaus.
Danke schön.
Ist auch jemand eine Idee?
Dann sage ich herzlichen Dank.
Wir sind uns ziemlich gut einig geworden.
Wir beiden.
Wir haben uns sehr gut gemacht.
Trauma ist nicht so beliebt.
Ich weiß das.
Aber es muss auch mal für eine Überraschung gut sein.
Ich würde sagen, sprach nicht.
War das ziemlich gut.
Von der Anamneseführung ziemlich komplett.
Ich fand auch die Darstellung gegenüber der Kollegin.
Ich glaube, der Kollege war okay.
Vielen Dank.
Wann ist Prüfung?
15.
Die Uhr hat sich getroffen.
Gehen Sie sehr entspannt rein.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt,
wer mein nächster Doktor ist.
Ich habe noch einen zweiten Fall für alle.
Ja, Herr Usluo.
Ich bin da.
Hallo, wir kennen uns auch schon.
Wir haben schon einmal eine gemacht.
Wir haben eine Falle gemacht.
Bevor wir starten,
darf ich mir schnell ein Teel holen?
Natürlich.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.